we begin today with the search for
two-year-old amari nicholson
he has been missing now for almost a
week the family just held a news
conference
asking the community to not give up the
search joe moeller was there he joins us
now live near paradise and twain with
more from that press conference hi joe
hi there alex the family of amari
nicholson was out here once again to get
the word out about his disappearance
and now they want more help from the
community they want help possibly
getting a website or
maybe getting a billboard like this one
you see here in the area where he went
missing he's been gone for now
six days he was last seen wednesday at
the emerald suites at paradise and twain
when he went missing his mother tells me
she was in colorado and her boyfriend
terrell rhodes was watching him
he told me in an interview last week
that someone from the father's side
picked him up
that family denies that ever happened as
days go on his aunts from omari's
father's side become more worried
it's been six days and we don't want the
public
to forget about omari we want to keep
his name out there we want to keep his
face out there
we're asking that if anyone could help
us get a billboard
for amari that would be useful if
someone could help us with a website
where the public could call in and give
any type of tips
metro police gave an update yesterday
afternoon saying they went door to door
in this area i asked if amari's mother
was helping the family out here they
tell me
she has not been in contact with anyone
from the father's side of the family now
back out here live you're taking
a live look at the emerald suites
complex where he was last seen which is
next door to where the family has been
meeting
now if you wanted to help with a website
or a billboard you can contact nevada
child seekers and they'll
get you set up on any sort of way that
you could help the family says the 30
thousand dollar reward
is still stands to find any information
uh leading to omar's whereabouts
reporting live here near paradise and
twain joe mullen 8 news now